yeah welcome to this video
chest tempo again I'm doing a couple of
tactics exercises starting here yeah
will be tough I really did well in the
last couple of ones and what is stir
yeah okay I really did well in the last
couple of ones and this means I will get
difficult problems okay we have a black
to move here and why it's last move was
we can look at this right yeah he took
on two hundy one which seems kind of
weird
this would be a puzzle I mean Luke takes
the one it's kind of the most normal
move ever that's really curious why why
is this a puzzle I mean okay maybe the
next move this is this is I understand
but is there something that I really
don't understand him
I don't get it so I'm taking it's a bit
weird why didn't they start with this
here
I mean who takes the one is very obvious
and anyway what about this okay white is
threatening not much he's threatening
and check on f8 maybe but even then King
age 5 wouldn't be made I mean okay can
take the bishop but we are voiding mates
in terms of active moves
I mean Quincy three years and pretty
obvious choice intending Queen f3 and
made to come if Queen c3 Queen f8 check
and also Bishop g7 and he won't be able
to cover every ya Quincy 3 looks very
very logical really what can he do to
prevent the major ook III looks like an
option then Queen a one threatening rook
g1 check then work h1 21 mate I doubt
that he can defend that really if it
does something like a 4 o g1 check King
f2 this even should be fires hmm
yeah Queen c3 looks very normal I just
wonder there's some trickery because
those new problems are notoriously
tricky
you know why is Quincy three move to
recognize it does a couple of things
here
it also covers the bishop on f6 I cannot
paint it unfortunately it covers the
bishop and it sets this this threat on
f3 so in this kind of situation you
sometimes just look for okay what would
be nice and you spot okay I have the
Queen I could check on that three would
be great
so Queen c3 is a natural candidate move
let's check the Queen c3 rupee three
Queen a1 he cannot block the first rank
King moves don't help pawn news don't
help either I don't see him it is wrong
I don't believe it
Quincy three is the most natural move
ever why is this wrong this is cheb step
before you queen a3 is better why is
Queen c3 wrong it's not even mentioned
this move why is this wrong tell me I
don't get it
there are a couple of Commons
he's gonna look sexy for Wow
I see a CSE yeah address this is the
this is the this is to move I don't I
don't still don't believe it
what is this so we check on g1 here this
what I can escape
now he can really escape this and it'll
always check on you for that's not
working
wait wait wait click here so this must
be the issue if I take now what what
exactly is the issue this is the problem
in my Leo yeah and you can easily lose
here so let's check and now you don't
have a decent shake I only have this one
and then this is this is working amazing
yeah you haven't the Edit yeah I should
have thought a little bit longer maybe
it's never that easy really never I
almost never okay next one costly that
costs 20 points okay
so again we've got Blackie in this
position very wild position so black has
an extra piece but where white has just
one corn but he's got play against the
wide-open King Knight f5 is it's one
particular problem
who came snide f5 okay
one obvious candidate move is night txt
to check was something to look at first
and I takes to D to check do we have
other candidates I mean just just doing
a trying to do it right do we have other
candidates I don't see it particularly
thrilling one even though of course we
are material up so it's not like they
look at form baby look at FOIA does make
quite some sense after looking for 9f5
we might even play King F 6 mm 996 this
is good for wide okay that's not working
okay for 95 I would need to take on a
five and that doesn't make oh wait that
doesn't make some sense if I take a GF
92 check but then you can go King a one
hmm now that that is fairly interesting
that's still fairly interesting that
also means that Knight f5 is probably
not such a youth threat even though
Knight f5 look at five Queen a 592 look
T to Queen d2 Quintus anachronisms check
is not check oh okay
like that five is not a real threat then
that is that is good to know
okay anyway night xt2 is the number one
candidate here 92 let's let's start with
the rook capture Queen d2 threatens made
on be 225 queenie fire some group to f6
hmm anything better there
you mean thankfully we are threatening
made on v2 let's say rook g 2f 695 check
Knight a5 check mmm
king a7 Quincy Quincy 7 it's no good hmm
Knight a5 King g6 night h4 check @ h4
checking f7 this is actually working but
he has rook h6 as well
Wow okay
and that Queen takes e5 move that is
really an issue it takes everything we
take c5 cannot ever King f-7s rook F 1
this is this is immediately immediately
a problem I can also if I play rook of
108 a6 then again I have 6 check
by the way I just I just saw another
candidate move sometimes you take a
while
Queen takes t2 is also a candidate and
it's sort of sloppy Queen takes t2 I
could have seen quicker it has a huge
advantage 5th to 9th ext2 Blackie a wife
cannot take on e5 that's a very
interesting actually
why doesn't have any meaningful checks
the only a snide f5 which I can just
take and I'm threatening made
okay so Queen did 20 X t2 what what can
you do what is it what can you play what
is actually possible night c2 may be
attacking the bishop on a3
oh okay Queen to Knight see - don't even
see Wow
what what are we playing then amazing
the bishop is also hanging
quint xt-1 Mukti one night it would
shake look T to look f1 check that's
nightly one unfortunately
otherwise that would be very nice but
the back rank is weakest maybe this is
something that we can use something like
I mean 22 night c2 and then a nights it
to look t8 maybe and then you can take
the knight on f3 route d6 there's a
check on age 7
rook h6 is move maybe Wow well this is
totally crazy if this is a solution that
that would be utterly crazy Queen d2 9f2
look h6 no item this is a kind of thing
when you see it you don't dare enter it
because you kind of know that it's wrong
but Queen d2 so 99022 problems because
of rooted to 20 to 25 okay there was
this look at formal which I haven't not
which I have not really refuted yet I
mean I didn't look at it that much
and there's Queen txt too which is I
mean looking very nice and therefore
therefore gets gets considered somehow
quintics g6 then is nuts doesn't work at
all
Queen d2 night c2 look aged six this is
what I'm thinking it's really crazy but
what does he have he cannot take on h6s
Queen D one mate what happens if he
takes the bishop by the way if he takes
the bishop on a3
hmm this is the real issue
somehow I feels like I'm overlooking
something
I mean what what you can do maybe is no
Queen d2 Knights it to Quincy three
there's also the check on d7 which seems
very irritating yeah yeah and rightly so
that is retaining hmm so I'm not getting
don't really get get for him after 22
night see - I mean I can just move the
bishop actually maybe this is the real
problem
yeah why not if I just move the bishop
from a3 yeah sure stupid yeah I can just
move the bishop maybe 26 blocking the D
file the knight on c2 is not doing
anything
he has no check on f5 and he has no
check in general he still cannot take on
the - maybe maybe this is really the the
solution hmm
yeah let's check that again I know I
didn't really look at through guy for so
it's not the purest form of candidates
ever but anyway Queen takes did - yeah
rocked it - it's easy I'm threatening
mate on B - he doesn't have any
meaningful check not a five I'm just
taking yeah it really there's really
only ninety two after which my bishop is
hanging on a three I tried the fancy
stuff but he would always take my bishop
so what if I removed the bishop that's a
2d six blocks the D file so next move I
can actually move the Queen so night C -
then Bishop d6 he doesn't have a check
that is a good thing I mean okay rook
age seven or whatever but nothing really
scary if he goes like rook f1 or
something up like whenever four okay
come on I make it I'm doing this move
now if it's wrong is wrong it is wrong
Wow it is wrong okay I don't really know
why why is it wrong I don't get it
so in 1962 this win yeah okay man I I
had this I was thinking I wished I just
thought okay that looks kind of tricky I
mean this is a very obvious line the
thing is that here I wasn't sure if I
can avoid the perpetual like here Knight
f5 wasn't most ants in Turkey to me
isn't that is not mentioned here know
what's for whatever reason that was the
only move that weren't me much how do i
how do i play now ha I can go no I
cannot
I can go here actually probably because
page six
I can maybe take that was what they were
did it retain in me a lot
9f5 I can I cannot take it and if I go
here this is probably really not good
kingi a dismayed King e6 also looks
there I'll tell you wrong
this is Queen g7 mate I mean what what
exactly was why don't they give this
line this is kind of crazy or isn't it's
not f5 so ridiculous I mean this is this
was my my problem move let's check out
the Commons
yeah I mean this is computer checked so
they are right they are right it's not
like I'm doubting that okay why is my
thing exactly not working
Queen txt - so Quinn texted you night
see - mmm okay now I was thinking 256
and how kids it's probably this man
intending Knight f5 again okay let's say
I take this
it seems entirely unclear I just lost 30
points due to that unbelievable you know
I have five is the only move now
probably poor why do I have to take it
all right very tough okay I mean I see
the problems I didn't see night III okay
let's do the next one and again again
such a defensive problem those are the
trickiest ones it's much easier if you
have something where you can I don't
know give a couple of checks and meet
the guy yeah then here where you just
see okay we'll go Bishop c3 and probably
chick made me Wow okay um so what is
this no but what did he take that
actually good night okay she's got one
pawn he's got one extra pawn and drew
takes a five so do I have I mean if I
take F they take the rook that's the
first move to check if I take the rook
the issue is Bishop c3 threatening made
on a Jade they cannot escape with the
kingless tweenage a check in e7 twin f6
checking 1807 made so after Bishop c3
it's very serious
I actually only have Bishop e3 check to
stop that Hui takes III and then rook
takes you for then it's going to easy
no it's annoying very annoying you seven
check King Queenie
8 check on e6 not good so she takes
Bishop c3 Bishop III check Queen takes
rook c4e 7 and it's not I don't really
have a move right
you sound threatening to take the Queen
and the and and the rook is on c4 so I
cannot really go Queen d7 or so we will
promote hmm okay I guess that's not
looking it really it's not what I cannot
take that damn look amazing
what else can I do I can try to click on
c4
Brooksie form look see for Quincy for
gf5 not easy Quincy is six men
it's very difficult okay um let's look
see for the candidate but it's not
complicated
what about Bishop g7 this was actually
my initial first move that I was
thinking of yeah attacking the queen
with the tempo and then take the rook
isn't that simple I mean why isn't that
working Kenny you cannot sacrifice the
Queen huh would be very very weird
no cannot do that
look f7 shaking gee it's not working
not ever I just now state that nah I
don't believe it
it's not working so he has to move the
Queen probably and then I take the rook
what is the problem you pawn again on if
someone was Queen d7 I don't get it
again I don't get it Bishop g7 what is
the problem
I mean that would have been I mean I
really don't see anything at all for
what anything at all
so take this now or is there still some
trick
I mean rook takes c4s is a move it's not
totally idiotic to consider but it's no
reason not to check this thankfully I
got some points there yeah okay so the
the key thing was that this immediately
is not working let's see they certainly
have some lines there no they don't even
don't even show that why I should show
it at least yeah Bishop c3 is the
problem threatening I cannot draw I want
to draw arrow King a Jade a queen edge
ain't made I only have that and now is
seven and this is the huge problem
that's eight sorry II ate threatened and
the capture threatened so if you block
this there's this and now it's it's
really bad the bishop is blocking G 7 h8
I only have this and this is made yeah
even with the rukns mate yeah so it was
nice okay let's do one more or at least
at last something with an attack okay
that that really looks like some mating
the ideas going one Queen e8 made some
mate there with the night and truck
would be cool
rook th check Bishop takes Queen before
check that's not leading anywhere
presumably anyway no that's not let's
not let's say let's check first what
of candidates we have
who saw what kind of material is that we
have a piece up here why right why
there's a pizza but g2 is of course
quite quite under fire the 87 rook is
undefended h8 Lucas undefended f6o
saying early a totally irritating
position okay I have no simple way to to
keep the peace at least I don't don't
see it hmm
I wonder if there's some kind of meeting
idea
hmm
I have some idea I don't know if it is
doing much good but night-night c5s
anymore somehow 95 and threatens night
CD 7 checkmate and if he takes with the
bishop I have the edge check King e7 and
we go from there like rook d7 King f8
night
h7 check something like this it could
could work but white is totally pinned
with everything so and after 95 there's
also the simple move G takes f6 after
which I'm not totally sure my responses
this magic takes F that's really really
a nuisance that can I do something about
that
I have 97 check but don't really see
what this is doing
other possible candidate most awesome
that I Queen D for so but I really
wonder I mean if he takes on f3 with the
bishop is not threatening a mate
immediately that's really an issue yeah
my own king is quite quite under
pressure
I wonder I mean something like Queen
before is an interesting move
threatening look t8 made bishop takes
before the a check King e7 rook d7
assisted is a draw at least is a draw
little yeah yeah but can we I mean
probably here and he probably has to it
has to force that wrong but I wonder of
course can we win yeah I mean we are at
peace up at the moment
but we have multiple things hanging
crazy pollution ready
an interesting move was also 94-94
intending maybe 96 is 6 and then for
discovery but I don't see what I'm doing
after GTX if he just takes my midnight
this is really the problem if you take
that night my most dangerous attacking
piece is gone
yeah and kundi for isms that I wonder
about attacking the rook but maybe he
can just go ahead and then click on g2
next may be very very irritating
position
I mean Queen before I think it's a drum
truth might be a draw G takes f roopd a
check King g7 queen is 7 that must be ok
I will take f6 as well but Queen before
Bishop takes routine check
King e7 is no alternative
whereas rook takes a jade threatening
rupee eight mate and man as it's totally
nonsense it's not going to work but we
have a draw Wow
early in the morning night you for I
mean if I just move that night away
therefrom Abbott aware 97 King d8 24 and
I don't know I really don't know I'm
just totally irritated
who needs seven for chicks
g7
that's interesting actually a rock d7
Bishop g2 look a seven is probably okay
he doesn't have any great discovered
check at least I don't see 187 G takes f
6 and then rookie 7 King is 7 check
might work rook d7 G F rookie sound king
his son cream before check King Agis GF
say six and then it's going to wish
every tune then I don't believe that
works so I think that Queen before is a
draw but I don't see anything better
really rook d7 do you have or do we have
something better
it's 797 okay I can take on f6 with
check of course and that's much much
stronger of course take there was chick
is much stronger hmm that's interesting
that works actually so is it route g7
after all
g7 again let's check this should have
six we have six and that thread through
T admit that that cannot work for black
okay I'm doing work t7 no but this is
like if it works it's great if not wow I
was right but I I couldn't I couldn't
really calculate it to the end okay yeah
well so I was originally thinking just
rook takes a seven because I didn't see
a great discovered check I just wonder
if there's something something better
manna it's very difficult to it's very
difficult to play some some slow moves
now in this position as he threatens the
discoveries I mean a move like I know 24
whatever this this is not going to work
if I take the rook let's just think
about this I'll take the rook then I'm a
rook up for the moment but I'm not
threatening much
this is something better
mr. king or anything
he really has just one check if he does
the discover discovery with the bishop I
just think if I take a 7gf what about
this I don't have Luke aah he can take
that with the bishop with the check this
is what irritates me a little bit maybe
just it takes f6 actually he doesn't
have a great square for that Bishop yeah
before this was checked see if I was
protected t6 is protected and Bishop d8
is Queen d6 and this just always just
one check with that bishop and I go to
have one okay so I can take the roof
Jesus I got that one right at least
that's what my Gamecock Maya was even
shivering off yeah so Maya found that
great I think I actually saw that
position it looked somewhat familiar but
I couldn't really couldn't really piece
it together its Queen before draw does
this what would be interesting to me
slight advantage to black here depth 13
I know what this is exactly mean this
isn't fly that wouldn't be very deep
Queen before gia VF Queen f6 gf
I was thinking rook to e8 here why isn't
roof d8 working I thought that this
would work why it's just not good there
is no check and I thought this it takes
f6 red would be would be dangerous is he
doing this
well what a crazy position okay let's
look at briefly here it took hit rook d7
he took took on D to Wien yeah that's
the only less serious move and then we
had so then we had this right look at
seven and here blackness is out of out
of checks EFS EF this is a porn yeah
that after this the sorry the bishop has
no square
they can't go nowhere c5 has taken
before has taken us check d6 is taken
bishop t 8s Queen d6 check wow that was
tough whoo okay so I did what did I do
in this set I think I got two or three
rights and two to were wrong right so
mad 50/50 or something yeah I'm okay
with that they are really really
difficult and as I said it's only in the
morning okay well thanks for watching